welcome to the et comic-con suite
everyone and what's so fun is we've been
doing interviews with all the biggest
celebrities all week and yet all of them
feature your giant poster on the side of
that hotel and I'm like we're talking
about all these shows and yet carnival
Row is taking over come on that's pretty
cool how does this feel huge activation
so much buzz and everyone's talking
about this show you've been working on
it for months and now it's exciting it's
yeah it feels it's so amazing to see the
buzz as well and everyone we've seen
anything yeah little glimpses of things
that we're doing so to have that much
enthusiasm towards something that
nobody's really seen much of as your
fans are really gonna this is definitely
something that the world needs right now
like I think this show is really gonna
feed the fans what they want to see you
so I'm excited oh yeah and so what was
it like I saw a little bit on the
Instagram live of you going through the
activation you guys checked it out what
card did you pick human creature humans
picked creature and I picked all
creatures but I was like fun right no
fun at all um so explain the show for
people who might not understand or have
heard about it yet um it's who wants to
tell you that should I take a little bit
read-through jumping so it's sort of
like a comment on life with the other if
you like we've got this
I play Rilo Philo Rycroft viola Phyllis
Frank who is a detective investigating a
murder on Carnival robe and carnival row
is this area where basically all of
these Fae remarkable creatures have who
are beings that have fled their war
homes or been brought in but they're
there they're basically sequestered to
this one area called Carnival Rogers in
the bug yeah our city which could be any
big city it's an 18th century Dickensian
feeling Co Victorian yeah kind of a cool
world even from what we've just seen s
on canvases so what you get is this this
what was once like a melting pot it is
yeah and it's and it's sort of a comment
on that life with the other so we're
looking a little bit at the refugee and
migrant crisis that's happening but
we're doing it with this fantasy
component which is really wonderful
because it lets you to be objective
without feeling invested in there you
can sort of look at this the situation
living in the world of the characters I
mean there's so many and they'll have a
history that we that plays out later and
Jeff they have something new which is
exciting and they have actually like
more of that meeting yes
okay so at the activation here comic-con
you were able to go and get your own
wings which was very comics are you
posting some of the super fabulous I
want to know for each of you if you
could put your wings on and flutter off
to somewhere and you didn't have to work
today where would you go oh well I am
back to the road to the road
I haven't huge wing Envy in the show
because I'm a human in the shows
I really want wings than the show that I
have to be content with a bus lot to do
doesn't have flying dreams Pyro's I
would go over to my family pick up my
logs making somewhere special and then
I've had to there you go okay it's not
your first round about with wings I want
to know is it CGI what was it like to
have wings on again and where they CJ
are these like the real wings with the
back so they are real but they are also
notice so obviously when you see me
flying that CGI but when we're kind of
standing you know the wings don't tend
to move a lot they're kind of they're
very sensitive the whole thing about
fairies are extremely sensitive
creatures but they're all about love and
giving back from you know taking and
giving back to the world what they have
and there are really amazing creatures
but yet really is really you know the
wings of that they're completely very
sensitive actually quite sensual they
they really respond to like a motion I
feel like fairies can feel and hear
things more than other people they feel
like well listen no one loves a costume
more than your love Katy Perry has
she'll try to steal anything from set
yes yeah she loves ceilings I can just
tell you that there any way that you can
like get a pair of the wings and take
them I might bring it back some of those
cardboard ones just a little gesture and
then she can snapchatting them and do
the whole tour okay I love that and this
weekend at Comic Con obviously your show
has debuted some of the trailers and
it's been a big buzz and other big buzz
is the cats trailer did you give Taylor
advice on acting let me know she does
not leave any advice on acting for me
she's an incredible performer I called
me to see cats it's gonna be great
everybody this oh really I feel like you
you didn't give her you didn't say like
good yeah maybe she's gone
especially with a cat yeah I feel like
anyone could if anyone's gonna be a cat
like living in a house being surrounded
by cats I think she said yeah it's gonna
be fine
and so what do you hope that people take
away from this show cuz like you said
there were some the themes are serious
but it is a fantasy I just hope that
people take the time to get into the
world because it is it is a episodes and
eight hours and there is so much beauty
and it is it's not like a lot of TV at
the moment which is so fast and so it's
it's beautiful and it's like real life
it's drawn out and there's so much in
between the lines and I really hope
people take the time to really see that
because I think that's the mystery
that's the joy of the TV yeah space now
isn't it and it doesn't feel like a TV
show it's work but this is my first time
in the space yes and it was it was it
was just like being on an ATAR
movie it was that the sets were
phenomenal you know you could really
gonna get like engaged in that world and
and I think you're drawn straight into
it now actually we kind of we really we
really they Amazon really committed to
the show in a major way we actually went
back and reshot some stuff earlier this
year because they were looking at how
the show could land and like show a big
yeah it's really new terminology new
creatures I know yeah but they're also
be different so I think yeah we you do
you need to spend some quality time
getting into it yes Labor Day weekend
just exactly thank you it's gotta be
something special for you to move from
film doesn't do something like this
so congratulations someone said it's a
great opportunity it looks so great
alright last thing we have asked your
girl many times about this wedding
planning every everybody here is invited
with questions like this we're inviting
the whole planet yeah bridezillas when
you're like I need 19 yeah we're doing
all that we're doing all the beautiful
things to kind of get to a space where
we feel super good about it so it's
great we're like working together too
it's fun it's one small process to
Travis and Mark yes a remarkable creator
or Travis HM who yeah come in and say hi
this is his this is his this is his
brainchild
I know this the casting the two of them
how old ifficult was that process and
we're the first really lost pics yeah it
was it took a while it took well and it
was it was really challenging because
you you know you're looking for these
these two characters are probably the
most mysterious in the show other
characters they declare themselves
upfront right away in the first five
minutes but these two they have a lot of
mystery they have a lot of mystique so
it took some looking but we really
landed I think yeah yeah what's your
reaction to people saying this is the
next game of Thrones I'm my ranch would
be this is the first carnival room
[Music]